Today, we're going
to talk about the
introduction of
musculoskeletal sonography.
Here are the objectives.
You'll understand
the appearances and
differences of tendons,
muscles, nerves,
bones, and bursa,
as well as asopatry.
You'll describe
common pathologies
such as neuropathy
and tendinosis,
and you'll able
to describe some
indications
and limitations
of musculoskeletal
ultrasound,
and recognize
various pathologies
compared with
normal anatomy.
So, sonography offers
many advantages that
other imaging modalities
do not. It's readily
available. It's
relatively inexpensive.
You can often do a
targeted exam, and it
can accommodate for
patient positioning, which
is ideal in patients
in the ICU setting.
It can be performed
in real time, so
you can do
productive maneuvers.
You can demonstrate
tendon subluxations,
as well as direct
needle placement
without any effects
of radiation.
It is used for
children in pregnancy
because it does
not have radiation.
And you can use it
for patients who
are claustrophobic
or have devices which
are not compatible
with MRI units.
This is a very
important term. Anything
with a star is very
important to know.
It may show up in
life as well as exams.
So the grayscale
terms. So this
is terminology
used in ultrasound.
So echogenesity refers
to the brightness
on the monitor. When
we say something's
hyperechoic, we mean it's
increased in echogenicity
compared to the
background tissue.
So this is brighter
than the background dark
gray tissue. When
something's isoechoic,
it's similar in echogenicity
to the background
tissue, which is
this middle example.
And if something's
hypoechoic, it's
darker than the
background tissue.
Anechoic is simple
fluid. It's completely
dark. It's black.
And then shadowing or
reflective is when
we have an area of
calcification or some
other increased density
where the beam is
reflected back and
we don't see anything
beneath it because
the sound waves hit
it and travel back. It
doesn't give us
information beneath it.
So getting into
some common normal
appearances is a very
important slide to know.
This is what
a tendon looks
like. They're
hyperechoic and
they have
alternating bands of
hypoechogenicity.
So they have these
alternating
hyperechoic, hypoechoic,
hyperechoic, hypoechoic
bands. It looks
like a fibular
pattern, we call it.
One of the residents
I used to work with
said it looked like a
braid of hair, so if
that helps you, there
are these alternating
bands of echogenicity.
It's very fiber-like.
This is a long view
of the Achilles
tendon. Here's the
Achilles tendon. This
here is bone. It's
reflective and they're
shadowing deep,
so this is your
calcineus. This over
here is muscle, which
we'll talk about,
but this is what a
normal tendon looks
like, hypo and hyper
echogenicity, um,
altered aiming bands.
Another important
slide, this slide in
general is very
important because it
captures all the
different tissues
that you're going to
see in ultrasound.
Muscle is more
hypochoic, means
it's darker. So
this is all muscle
over here. These
axes are tendons.
Tendons you can
see are brighter.
And it has these
hypochoic lines of the
fibro fatty septa
and often has a
marbled appearance. So
you have these bright
lines in the
background of tissues,
sort of if you think
of like a steak.
background of dark
tissue, and then
these fibro fatty
bands in between it.
All these septations
will eventually
converge to a central
tendon, a central tendon
slip, which attaches
to this tendon.
And in the transverse
appearance,
we say this has
a starry sky
appearance because
there's bright dots
in the background
of dark tissue.
So this is bone here.
This is the humeral
head. Here's the tendon.
Here's the muscle.
Ligaments are
hyperechoic. This is the
ligament right here.
It's hyperechoic.
They're more compact
than tendons, so
they're densely
braided hairs. So this
is the radiocollateral
ligament going
from the radius to
the distohumerus.
So here is the ligament
over here. It's
hyperechoic.
Here's a background
tissue of bone.
So the arrow is
pointing to the
bone. This is
the humeral head.
has that line by
the arrow. So here
we'll head. It's
reflective. So it has
a smooth contour. We
don't say anything
to it. Here is
the tendon, right?
Here's the bone.
Here's the muscle,
dark with the
fibrofaceptus.
So muscle, tendon, bone.
The final layer we're
going to talk about
is the epidermis and
the skin. So here is
the skin soft tissue
that you can see,
which is bright with
the subcutaneous fat.
The subcutaneous
fat is hypoechoic,
while the epidermis
dermis is usually
a single layer and
it's hypoechoic.
There are two
different types of
cartilage. There's the
fibrocartilage which
you see in labrum
and menisci, which
is this bright
triangle right here.
As opposed to your
hyaline cartilage
which is this dark
tissue right here,
which is what the patella,
this is the femoral
chocolate cartilage,
the patella would
sit here and sort of glide
against the cartilage.
So the patella
femoral cartilage or
hyaline cartilage
is hypochoic and
the fibrocartilage
which is more dense
tissue is bright.
Very important to know is
nerves. Nerves
are rounded.
They're hypochoic with
a hyperechoic rim so
they almost have a
honeycomb type of
appearance. So the nerve
fascicle which is this
honeycomb part here is
outlined by fat which
is the perineum around
the nerve and it
causes this honeycomb
type of appearance. So
right here is a nerve
and we have the nerve
fascicles of dark
and the bright fats
surrounding him. The
epineurum that surrounds
him is this bright stuff
here sort of mimicking
this honeycomb type
of appearance. Now
when you're different
when you're practicing
and we're doing ultrasound
you can actually
see the difference
between the nerve and
tendons because the
tendons will move and
the nerve will sort of
just bounce back and
forth but not actually
physically move. You
won't see the tendons
stop movement. We'll
talk about anisopatry
in a little bit, which
is this artifact that
we're seeing here.
So anisopatry, very,
very important to know.
This is an artifact.
It causes an apparent
decreased echogenesis
to the tendons
because the ultrasound
beam is not exactly
parallel to the tendon
that we're looking at.
So if it's not exactly
parallel to it, the
tendons may have this
falsely decreased
acogenesis right here
because not all the
sound waves are being sent
out are being received
by the probe so if
the probe is sort
of cockeyed over here
not all the bums not
all the sound waves are
coming out are being
received by that
probe this the probe
interface is straight
over for this the probe
would be sort of like
this way when we're
sending out sound waves
not all of them are
receiving back so the
probe has to be 90
degrees to the structure
you're looking at,
the tendon you're looking
at. If not, it has
this falsely decreased
appearance to it.
The difference between
this and tendinosis,
which we'll talk
about in a little
while, is the tendon
in tendinosis, the
actual tendon morphology
will change. It
becomes more round
appearance and swollen.
In this, the normal
tendon has this oblong
type shape here. You
can see that even
in esoptery, it
maintains this oblong
shape. But when you
have tendinosis, you
actually have fluid
entering the tendon and
it has a more of a
rounded appearance.
So we're going
to talk some
basic pathologies.
So tendinosis.
Tendinosis, like I
just said, the tendon
swells. It's hypoechoic.
And the reason
why it's swelling is
because it's fluid.
And fluid is hypoechoic
in ultrasound.
So it has this
darker appearance
because there's
more fluid. Fluid
being hypoechoic,
it becomes darker.
You often have
indistinct margins to
it and you may
have some increased
vascularity related
to neovascularity.
Here's what a normal
tendon looks like.
This is the Achilles
tendon. This is an
abnormal Achilles
tendon that's swollen.
So, which one's normal,
which one's not?
Here's a normal
tendon, alternating
bands of hypo and
hypoarchogenicity.
Here, the tendon is
diffusely swollen
and enlarged. It
changes morphology,
so the left side
has tendinosis.
Tendon tears,
I'm only going to
touch about in a
minute, for a minute,
real quick, in
terms of tears.
So tears, when
you have a tear of
the tendon, you're
usually in spaces
where fluid can
fill that space.
So the tendons will
have a dark foci
in it, so they have
a dark foci, and
that's fluid that
fills that tendon gap.
This over here is
an example of a
full thickness
tear of the tendon.
Here's the humeral
head, here's part
of the supraspinatus
tendon, and then
you have this full
thickness gap.
This is the Achilles
tendon right here with
this gap of dark stuff
filling the middle
of the tendon, which
is fluid. So this would
we would consider a
partial tear. It doesn't
go completely across
the tendon or full
thickness tear will
completely across the
tendon to hold weight
thickness of the tendon.
Neuropathy, good
to know. You may
see an example of
this on the exam.
So now neuropathy happens
from entrapment, tumors.
You can look at the
nerve subluxation,
that can cause it.
So it's an increased
size and decreased
echogenicity of
the nerve itself.
And the reason why it
has decreased
echogenicity is because
it's swollen, it's
filled with fluid,
and fluid being dark.
Here is the ulnar
nerve over here,
here we're measuring
the ulnar nerve
proximal, and then
at the level of
neuropathy we can see
that the nerve
completely swells up.
So normal nerve, and then
neuropathy, the
nerve is swollen,
hypoechoic, because
it's inflamed.
So I'm going to do a
couple of case examples
to round out this
quick PowerPoint
presentation of
Musculoskeletal Ultrasound.
So here's an 18
-year-old female that
presents with shoulder
pain after attempting
to do CrossFit
shoulder press, she has
a history of pacemaker,
heart disease,
she has a limited
exam due to pain
so the doctor can
really examine
them, and now what
are the appropriate
next tests? We
can do an x-ray,
a CAT scan,
MRI or Ultrasound,
those are
the next tests we can do.
When thinking about
this, we have to think
of what our differential
may be. So our
differential for
someone who has acute
shoulder pain after an
exercise could be, well,
do they have a soft
tissue injury? Did
they injure their rotator
cuff or the labrum?
Could they have
possibly fractured it?
Maybe they have a
problem with the tendon
structure itself.
Maybe they have a
problem called calcific
tendinosis, which
is calcific deposits
within the tendon.
Or maybe it's a tumor.
It's not a tumor.
So the first step
would be an x-ray. So
here's the clavicle.
Here's your chromium,
here's your humeral
head, your coricord
process, and your
glenoid. And the humeral
head is sitting within
the glenoid fossa.
We can outline
the margins of the
humerus, so the cortex
is nice and smooth,
so we know there's
no fractures.
This is a transcapital
wide view, which
means that the x
-ray came like this
to look at the
glenoid on the fossa.
Here's the glenoid,
here's the humeral
head, so there's
no dislocation.
If there's anterior
dislocation,
this humeral head
would have been over
here. If it's
the posterior
dislocation, it would
have been out here.
Here's the
acromocabicular joint.
So this, on
this radiograph,
we rule that
that's not fracture
and there's no
dislocation.
Now x-rays are not
good to look at
the soft tissues.
So what we can
do next is we can
do something that
has better soft
tissue resolution.
So what do we rule
out? So we ruled
out that we didn't
see a fracture.
We didn't see any calcific
deposits. calcific
deposit would be
white like this in the
tendons we didn't see
any of that and we don't
see any masses in the
bones the bones don't
look homogeneous we
don't see any tumors so
we ruled out those
things and the reason
why i said somewhat here
is because for a tumor
to be seen on radiographs
you need about
50 of the cortex to be
destroyed before you
can see it so what do
we do next we different
modalities. We can do
a CAT scan, an MRI,
or else. So CAT scan
carries radiation
because it
involves radiation.
It's good to look
at fractures.
It's not so great
for the soft
tissues, but we
can do a technique,
which they did in
the old days, and
we still do for
sometimes today,
is we'll put a dye
in the joint. We
can look for rotator
cuff or label tears,
but it's not the
primary reality.
The gold standard
to look for
the rotator cuff
in pathology
or labral pathology
is the MRI.
However, we can't
do in this case,
and the reason
why we cannot is
because the patient
has a pacemaker.
So ultrasound is an
ideal for this patient.
It does not carry
radiation. You can do
testing of it, and it's
not good for the osseous
pathology, but it may
be for some indications.
We'll talk about
that in a little bit.
So what can we see
on ultrasound? We can
look at the rotator
cuff tendons, and I'm
sure you guys know
what they are. The
biceps tendons, the
acromocabicular joint,
the glomerular joint,
and we can look at
the various nerves
around the shoulder.
I'm not gonna
go over this too
much. You guys
should know about
this in anatomy,
the sitz muscles.
Here's a schematic
of the shoulder. This
is a sagittal MRI.
This is your chromium.
Here's your glomerular
head. This little
black dot right
here is the biceps
tendon. You have your
supraspinatus tendon,
you have your
infraspinatus tendon,
your teres minor
muscle tendon right
there on the
muscle, and we have
your subscapularis
muscle and tendon.
This is an arthrogram
where we put
fluid in the joint.
That's why there's
so much stuff around
the humo head.
Here's a picture of it as
well, same type
of orientation.
So this is what the
ultrasound looks like.
This right here is
the biceps tendon.
It's bright. It
has echogenicity.
This is the subscapularis
tendon, which is
the anterior. It gives
the humeral head.
And then we have your
supraspinatus
tendon right here.
This is the
supraspinatus tendon
with the bone
right below it. And
then we have
your teres minor.
I'm sorry, your
spinaeus tendon right
here. And then we
have your teres minor
right here with the
bone right below it.
This is this person's
supraspinatus tendon.
Well, it looks more
swollen if we look
compared to the tendon
size on this, and
we have this dark
cleft in it, which we
don't have in these
other tendons. These
other tendons are
homogeneously bright
throughout. We don't
have these dark clefts in
it. So this dark
cleft over here may be
a problem. So what can
we do? We can confirm
it with another view
or looking at the
other side, which is
great for symmetry.
So this is the left.
Here's the right.
The right is swollen
compared to the
other side, it's
darker compared to
the other side, and
it has this cleft
of fluid, but dark
with it. So this is
a tear of the
supraspinatus tendon.
So they have a
high-grade partial
tear. It doesn't go
all the way across,
so it's not full
thickness tear.
It's the partial,
what we call partial
tear, of the
supraspinatus tendon.
Now I don't expect
you guys to all know
this. We're just trying
to point out some
common pathologies
that you can find.
The bulk of what you're
gonna have to know
for your exams and
everything is was
highlighted in the first
part where I talked
about all the different
pathologies this is
sort of just highlighting
that to reinforcers
so case two is a 40
year old rheumatologist
who injured their
hand tickling their
child so a couple
differentials we have
collateral ligaments
we have tendons you can
get a fracture we get
a pulley injury which
stabilized the tendons
along the fingers.
So I didn't also
tell this person, so
this is the bright
bone, here's the bright
cortex of the bone,
bone, bone, bone,
bone, bone, and then
there's a defect or
a gap in it. Here's
that bone continued,
bone, the bone should
be one continuous
surface, our bones
don't have gaps, it
should be one smooth
surface. So this
right here is suspicious
for a fracture.
So after this I did
it, we did an x-ray,
and we got this so this
is our fifth metacarpal
this is the fifth
metacarpal right here
the full fifth digit
and we can see that
there's a break right
here this is a fifth
metacarpal fracture
and this is a specific
type of fracture
this is a pathologic
fracture through a benign
bone tumor that you
can get in the finger
called an enchondroma
so the enchondroma
erodes the bone make
the cortex very thin
so any minor trauma
such as tickling your
child can cause that
the fracture so this
This is a pathologic
fracture of the fifth
metacarpal neck due to
an encodroma, which
we saw in ultrasound.
And this is what
normal would look
like. This is what
normal looks like.
This is the
encodroma right here.
I spoke about
this already.
Case 3.
Case 3. This is a
45-year-old with
increased pain swelling
behind the knee. No
past medical history,
but does not want
to do x-ray because
of radiation. So,
some of our differential
we can think
of is maybe they
have a blood clot or
a DVT, which you
always have to consider
when you have leg
pain and swelling.
Maybe it's a mass,
it can be some
type of tumor such
as a sarcoma or
lipoma, which is
benign, can be benign,
you can get nerve
sheath tumors, or maybe
it's a cyst that
developed behind the knee.
So what can we do?
Because they refuse
x-rays and the
insurance company
will not like to
go to an MRI first,
we can start with
an ultrasound
because it doesn't
carry any radiation.
This is the left
side behind the
leg. These round
circles here
are the vessels
behind the knee.
And we go to the right
side in the popliteal
fossa, the same
area, we can see that
there's this dark
structure. Here's your
gastrocnemius muscle.
This is your gastrocnemius
muscle on the other
side. You have this
area of anechoic
collection behind the knee.
So what can this
possibly be?
This anechoic election
is a Baker's cyst
or popliteal cyst.
The popliteal cyst
and the corresponding
MRI, an example,
occurs between the
semimerminosis and the
medial head, the
gastrocnemius muscle.
And you can see that
there's a little
tail that travels
between the tendons.
That's how we know
it's a Baker's
cyst. And this
tail is right here.
Here's your medial
head, gastrocnemius.
Your semimerminosis
is over
here. This is
that little tail.
So this is a popliteal
cyst. These cysts
can cause pain because
they can compress.
They can also rupture
and cause acute
pain. So what can we
do for them? Well, I
can offer the patient
some pain relief as a
radiologist and then
I can put my needle,
and this is my drainage
of a needle going
into it, and I can
take that fluid out
and I can aspirate
out and then inject a
steroid in there to
decrease the inflammation
of that cyst. So
if that's what we
do, we can do a popliteal
cyst aspiration.
This is our last
case, it's a 35
year old weekend
warrior with
posterior ankle
pain and swelling.
So once again, we
have leg pain and
swelling, so DVT is
one thing to consider.
Since they're down at
the ankle, we consider
Achilles tendon or
plantar tyros tendon,
also known as tennis
leg, muscle strain
or herniation, or
even some type of
plantar fascia problem.
So the x-rays first.
Here's the tibia.
Here's your fibula.
This is your talus.
Here's your calcaneus.
Once again we have
your tibia and the
background over here
is the fibula. So we
don't see any fractures
of the bone. The
cortices are all
smooth and continuous.
So we did an
ultrasound. In
the ultrasound,
here's your
symptomatic right
side. This is
the Achilles
tendon. This is your
asymptomatic left
side. Here's your
calcineus. This
is your tendon.
This is your tendon.
So on the right
side, we can see that
this is much larger
than the other side
and it's darker.
So when we said
that before, we said
the tendon's large
and darker. It has
tendinosis. We call
that tendinosis.
We said that it may
get increased blood
supply to it because
of neovascularity,
which we do have here
because the tendon's
mad. And then here,
here's the morphology
of the tendon,
which is swollen. So
this is an example of
Achilles tendinosis.
So hopefully from this
you've learned that
muscle ultrasound
can be dynamic, you
can be formed by
the radiologist and
technologist, and you
can develop an anatomic
relation to the
adjacent structures, and
knowing the patient
history you can form
a better diagnosis,
and you can use
ultrasound as an
adjunct developing for
figuring out what's
wrong with your patient.
If you have
any questions,
please reach out.
Thank you.